et
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
bruno retailleau a le sénateur de vendée
et président du groupe l'est républicain
au sénat rebonjour bruno retailleau
bonjour à vous alors nous sommes
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenter ce
matin par le groupe ebra des journaux de
l'est de la france avec vous fabrice
veysseyre redon bonjour fabrice
vous n'avez pas l'habitude alors on va
commencer évidemment bruno retailleau
paraît bien évoqué le grand meeting de
valérie pécresse qui était censée
relancer à sa campagne c'était hier au
zénith de paris est ce que pour vous
l'objectif a été atteint est-ce que ça
va créer une nouvelle dynamique et
goûtez moi j'ai jamais pensé d'ailleurs
qu'un seul meeting pouvait relancer
abbey c'est une dynamique simplement
j'étais satisfait de du meeting d'hier
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
qu'il y avait une vraie ferveur les
salles étaient pleines que pratiquement
huit mille militants c'est important
mais surtout on avait un discours sur
une ligne de droite qui est assumé un
discours de vérité elle a dit que on
peut pas continuer à travailler de moins
en moins on ne pouvait pas non plus
continuer à dépenser de plus en plus et
puis elle a donné du sens à toutes les
mesures qu'elle avait égréné depuis deux
mois et le sens c'est la france parce
que dans une france qui est désunie je
pense que ce que nous avons de commun
précisément c'est la france c'est ce qui
nous relie et je pense qu'il a bien
exprimé son programme c'est de bâtir une
nouvelle france avant d'évoquer le fonds
est justement son discours de droite
assumé une question sur la forme est ce
que vous trouvez qu'elle a eue le ton
juste on avait un petit peu l'impression
que quand même c'était son premier grand
meeting d'une campagne présidentielle et
que ça ne s'improvise pas et parfois ça
sonnait un peu faux comment vous l'avez
recensé ça n'est pas que ça sonnait un
peu faux c'est que ça n'est pas tout
simplement la forme dans laquelle elle
est la plus à l'aise vous la mettez sur
un plateau pour débattre vous la mettez
dans une salle où elle va y avoir une
interaction une proximité avec son
public où il va y avoir des questions
des réponses est là elle est excellente
voilà je pense que c'est important mais
je donnais hier soir deux exemples
premier exemple c'est angela merkel
est-ce que vous avez déjà suivi discours
d'angela merkel c'est ennuyeux à mourir
voilà et pourtant c'était une grande
chancelière vous avez suivi bien sûr les
discours des mails mc ren ai moi aussi
je n'ai vu c'était pas ça on a bien ils
ont souvent été le masque même lorsque
petit à petit la prix ils ont été
souvent le masque de l'impuissance des
renoncements et des retournements donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire moi ce que je
demande à un président de la république
à une pression de la république c'est de
gouverner c'est que les mots colle avec
les actes ou ce que nous n'avons pas
eues avec les mâles macro et d'ailleurs
hier c'était assez surprenant je me
faisais cette réflexion moi qui étais
premier rang dans le public vers ip
tressières elle a annoncé ce qu'elle
fera pendant cinq ans pendant que mails
macron lui annonce le contraire de ce
qu'il n'a pas fait depuis cinq ans au
fil des semaines bruno retailleau ce
meeting d'hier pas des jours a été
présenté comme le meeting de la dernière
chance un stupide ouais vous pensez que
c'est sûr mais j'ai franchement reportez
vous à toutes les autres élections ya
jamais eu un meeting qui a pu décider du
sort d'une élection présidentielle ça
c'est archi faux je ne sais pas où ça a
été installé peut-être même parfois dans
nos propres rangs mais je pense que une
campagne est une campagne électorale
présidentielle c'est une forme de
liturgie républicaine bien sûr les
mythiques ça compte mais il nous reste
deux mois et je pense qu'il faut
convaincre d'autant plus qu' il ya un
état particulier de l'opinion les
français sont un peu distanciée par
rapport à la politique a eu un excellent
sondage du cevipof ya quelques jours qui
montre l extrême méfiance voire défiance
des français vis-à-vis de la politique
bien moi je pense que justement le
lyrisme des discours les français sont
blasés ce qu'ils veulent désormais ce
sont des actes et je pense que ce que
porte en elle valérie pécresse avec
cette volonté de faire f 1 er et f ier
re correspond est accordée avec cette
terre du temps cette méfiance et elle
porte une forme de pragmatisme
c'était de faire c'était le slow quand
votre candidat françois fillon en or
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai c'était le
slogan de françois fillon alors vous
allez alors vous disiez les actions
importants mais les mots aussi justement
et pour la première fois valérie
pécresse a utilisé hier le mot grand
emplacement un concept clé du programme
d'eric zemmour si elle a bien fait
d'utiliser ce nom c'est incroyable vous
êtes pour vous ça n'a pas de
signification mais novès qu'est ce
qu'elle a dit elle a dit justement il
n'y a pas de fatalité ni placement ni
grand déclassement et d'adil inverse et
est maintenant vous êtes un certain
nombre de commentateurs à lui faire un
procès qui est un procès totalement un
procès non un nom je vous réponds
insurgés ça pousse inquiétez pas je suis
pas en train de vous critiquez vous mais
je t'ai j'écoutais ce discours je sais
ce qu'elle a dans sa tête donc voilà
c'est tout simplement oui il ya un
problème en france et qu'on a perdu
totalement le contrôle de l'immigration
vous prenez tous les chapitres de
l'immigration que ce soit sur le soin
que ce soit sur l'asile que ce soit sur
le regroupement familial et cetera et
cetera on fait on est un des pays les
plus accueillants d'amp le pays sans
doute le plus accueillant d'europe l'an
dernier il n'y a jamais eu autant de
titres de séjour de dix livres et en
france emmanuel macron aura été ce
président de république contrairement
d'ailleurs à tous ses collègues des
autres pays européens qui aura faciliter
le regroupement familial dont oui il
faut reprendre la maîtrise des flux
migratoires c'est une urgence c'est ce
que demandent les français et d'ailleurs
elle s'est engagée et nous modifierons
la constitution pour le faire à faire
très très rapidement dans les 200 jours
un référendum sur cette question parce
que c'est une question qui a bouleversé
la société et on a toujours tenu à
l'écart
cette question-là importante les
français donc faller et pécresse où l'on
vous a eu raison de reprendre ses termes
qui sont d'ordinaire très utilisé plutôt
utilisé par
la famille d'être à droite elle n'ya pas
d'abord y a pas de tabou ensuite elle
peut prononcer les termes qu'elle
choisit et enfin elle l'a prononcée dans
une autre acception en lui réservant
pour dire qu' elle refusait qui est à la
fois un grand remplacement est un grand
déclassement donc on marche sur la tête
mais là encore et c'est important pour
elle il faut lutter contre la police de
la pensée médiatique ou politique
ça c'est fondamental
les gens en ont marre du politiquement
correct
et parce que la droite a eu peur de ce
politiquement correct parce que la
droite a vécu sous l'hégémonie
médiatique intellectuelle de la gauche
on a perdu des électeurs parce qu'on a
baissé le regard on a courbé l échine et
bien désormais plus jamais ça une droite
une ligne de droite assumé c'est ce
qu'elle a fait hier et avec un discours
de fermeté vis-à-vis du port du voile je
vais la cité pour moi le voile n'est pas
un vêtement comme un autre c'est un
signe de soumission mois président de la
république aucune femme ne sera soumise
marianne n'est pas une femme voilée
bruno retailleau et cela l'expression
alors est ce que ce sont juste des
phrases mais ce que dans son programme
il y aura d interdiction du port du
voile dans certaines circonstances bien
sûr elle a été celle qui a porté
d'ailleurs l'initiative de
l'interdiction de la burqa en 2010 à
l'époque elle était je vous le rappelle
députés elle était comme moi elle à
l'assemblée mois au sénat celle qui a
constitué le groupe de soutien aux
chrétiens d'orient et notamment quand
ils étaient persécutés par l'état
islamiste et bien sûr nous assumerons
par exemple l'interdiction du voile pour
le sport regarder les discours des mails
altran contre l'islamisme et dès lors
qu'il faut poser des actes il ya plus
personne c'est quand même simple il ya
des hidjabs buzz qui sont des militantes
qui veulent imposer ce signe qui est un
signe d' apartheid sexuel qui est un
signe de sa soumission de la femme et
toute la macro 10e couche regarder la
cacophonie au gouvernement nous
l'interdire on nous interdirons aussi
dans les piscines dans des lieux fermés
comme elle l'a fait d'ailleurs récemment
d'ailleurs elle est allée au tribunal
pour cela pour les lieux notamment de
baignade qui sont des lieux fermés nous
interdirons ces signes ostentatoires ses
sorties scolaires aux sinistrés lumière
sur les sorties scolaires c'est aussi
c'est aussi au programme donc nous
serons intraitables avec l'islamisme qui
est en train de gangréner la france
aujourd'hui même vous le savez s'ouvre
le procès du des assassins et des
complices surtout puisque les deux
assassins sont mort du père hamel donc
il ya une tentative en france sur le sol
français d'imposer la charia samuel
patty est mort parce que justement
certains ont voulu imposer la charia et
ont voulu lui faire payer sa liberté
d'expression la liberté qu'à chaque
enseignant a pour renseigner précisément
les jeunes français elle soutient
également la construction de murs ou de
barrières aux frontières européennes là
aussi on a l'impression que c'est un peu
une nouveauté dans son discours on
entendait beaucoup dans le programme
d'eric zemmour c'est aussi un élément de
2,3 droitisation de son programme non
elle a raison on regarder ce qui s'est
passé et l'étaler d'ailleurs gérard
larcher est allé avant elle il pourrait
dire la même chose que ce que je vous
dis ce matin en grèce notamment sur les
îles qui sont en première ligne ils ont
divisé par huit l'immigration
clandestine comment ils ont fait ils ont
dressé c'est vrai des défenses des
barrières physiques et puis des centres
où on accueille les immigrés de façon
humaine mais on les retient dans ces
centres lorsque ils n'ont pas vocation à
s'implanter durablement en europe bien
sûr qu'il faut de la fermeté parce que
quand on n'a pas de la fermeté quand on
laisse la place au laxisme
on dégage la voie à toutes les mafias
les mafias qui font le trafic d'êtres
humains donc l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions trop souvent et et tous ceux
qui voulant qu'ils voudraient les no
borders qui veulent supprimer les
frontières en réalité apportent leur
aide à ces mafias qui vivent et qui
récoltent des milliards d'euros il ya eu
un certain nombre de chiffres qui ont
circulé donc il faut la fermeté pour
décourager ces flux là encore monsieur
erdogan
l'autocrate biélorusse l'a fait on voit
qu'on a des guerres asymétriques fopac
naïfs nous ne serons plus naïfs nous
avons été trop longtemps 9 et c'est vrai
que le roi de la naïveté qui en
l'occurrence de ce point de vue là c'est
mal macron alors dans le discours
valérie pécresse je le disais à utiliser
certains mots qui sont souvent employées
par exemple citer nommément le candidat
du parti en reconquête en revanche lui
dans son discours la veille en côte-d'or
et bien il a un peu attaquées à l'épée
valérie pécresse je le cite un valérie
pécresse n'est pas de droite c'est une
technocrate de centre-droit qui ne
vaudra pas mieux que le centre gauche a
des manuels macron rendez vous pour le
retail non mais ça c'est eric zemmour ce
que je dis simplement c'est que ne
trompons pas ce qu'elle a quand même
cette image de celles et ceux toutes
celles et ceux qui ne veulent pas kemmel
macron fasse un second quinquennat doit
voter valérie pécresse elle est la seule
de très très loin tous les sondages le
disent lorsqu'elle est au second taux et
nous battrons et belle macro en revanche
celles et ceux qui vont voter marine le
pen ou monsieur eric zemmour apporteront
une chance de plus ml macron de
prolonger pour un second mandat sa
présidence et ça pour moi c'est clair
par ailleurs exe moore je suis désolé on
demande un électricien d'être formés en
demande à un plombier d'être formés et
et un prénom république on peut
s'improviser moi je n'y crois pas du
tout il ne gouvernera pas il apporterait
beaucoup plus de désordre que d'ordre de
discorde que d'unités françaises c'est
un intellectuel et il fait parfois des
constats qui sont des ponts constat
simplement il ya un esprit de système
est un intellectuel un esprit système ça
mais connaît souvent la complexité des
choses humaines d'où les erreurs qu'il a
pu connaître sur l'inclusion des
handicapés douce avait ses enfants juifs
qui avaient été massacrés par mohamed
merah à toulouse a à chaque fois voyez
ça révèle quelque chose et encore une
fois on ne s'improvise pas vous avez su
ménager bruno retailleau vous ménager un
peu avec ces mots est ce que est ce que
vous auriez par exemple la crainte d'une
diabolisation et du personnage et son
électorat écoutez j'ai toujours
considéré que la moraline en politique
c'était pire que tout parce que ça ne
fait pas avancer les choses on a une
expérience maintenant de plus de 30 ans
avec le front national puis
rassemblement national la stratégie
droite et gauche confondues souvent ça a
été finalement la diabolisation et alors
on n'a fait que renforcer non moi je
pense que il faut démontrer aux français
sans ostraciser les français les
français qui votent pour tel ou tel sont
pas des parias se sont souvent
d'ailleurs des gens qui ont été déçus
par la droite on a le droit de leur
parler et de les respecter et je pense
que quand on est aux politiques on doit
respecter l'adversaire même quand on
n'est pas d'accord avec lui en revanche
là aussi il faut dénoncer soit les
écarts de langage ou alors les fausses
solutions voilà regardez les 10000 euros
par enfant en milieu rural c'est du
grand n'importe quoi moi je veux une
politique et je reproché à la gauche
qu'elle des faces l'universalité des
allocations familiales les allocations
familiales c'est quand on a un enfant
quel que soit le revenu quel que soit la
situation la gauche françois hollande
puis mme malmat kron a dit non quelles
que soient leurs revenus ça va dépendre
donc on a cassé cette politique
familiale ce n'est pas pour établir des
critères qui ne seraient plus des
critères de revenus et des critères de
territoire vous voyez c'est sait comment
dirais-je une anti politique familiale
cette perception on peut avoir des
choses cette politique familiale on la
porte droite et gauche confondues
d'ailleurs y compris avec le parti
communiste depuis la guerre et depuis le
gaullisme alors bon on ne reconnaissait
bournot retailleau pardon ça ne vous a
pas échappé eu quelques départs du parti
des républicains ces derniers temps avec
l'ancien ministre de nicolas sarkozy
eric woerth qui a rallié emmanuel macron
également la maire de calais ancienne
sénatrice natacha bouchart qui rallie la
macro ni pendant cette campagne
présidentielle est ce que finalement
peut-être le discours trop droitier de
la pécresse ça entraîne une fuite de
certains cadres et l'air chez emmanuel
macron donc ces débauchages sont des
débauchages individuels quelqu'un avait
dit un jour là où il ya de l'homme il ya
de l'hommerie voilà ce qui signifie que
vous n'empêcherez jamais de quelqu'un
d'oublier ses convictions de les renier
pour poursuivre grâce à des petits
calculs électoralistes ses propres
intérêts ça c'est la loi humaine c'est
la loi en politique c'est la loi dans la
vie tout court c'est terrible
quand on connaît des gens dont on a eu
une forme de relation d'amitié avec eux
mais faut pas s'en étonner ou alors
quand on s'en étonne c'est qu'on connaît
mal la vie tout simplement c'est la
nature humaine alors quand même il ya
quand même un soutien qui est important
et qui pour l'instant n'est pas effectif
et qui sera important pour valérie
pécresse est celui de l'ancien président
de la république nicolas sarkozy il
n'était pas présent au meeting hier et
selon le journal le figaro il est très
critique envers la candidate des
républicains
ça va commencer à poser problème cette
absence de soutien nicolas sartini
devons manger aucun doute sur le soutien
de nicolas sarkozy à la candidate de sa
propre famille politique aucun doute que
vous avez des informations du jeu je le
vois tout à l'heure voyez pas ce que je
veux j'ai été chargée de ce travail
décent jour où des 200 jours et il a lui
et il y en a peu dans son cas l'habitude
de cet exercice du pouvoir donc je veux
essayer de confronter et quelques idées
que je peux avoir les soumettra à son
avis mais je n'en doute pas du tout je
ne vois pas du tout je veux te dire
non non non je suivais tout simplement
parce que je me pose un certain nombre
de questions pour organiser les
premières semaines les premiers mois du
quinquennat de valérie pécresse et je
pense qu'il peut être très très utile
c'est à nicolas sarkozy qu'on prête le
nom de christine lagarde pour un futur
poste de premier ministre à matignon
dans le cadre d'un deuxième mandat d'
des menus et le maquereau vous en pensez
quoi rien du tout plu il fixe y compris
du tout prêt du tout on a entendu une
question sur l'actualité cette semaine
au sénat vous évoqué l affaire des
hidjabs deux ans et ce collectif de
femmes voilées qui demandent le droit de
jouer au foot depuis 2020 car la
fédération française de football
l'interdît jusqu'à aujourd'hui et dans
une proposition de loi sur la
démocratisation du sport les sénateurs
de droite veulent interdire le port de
signes religieux dans les compétitions
sportives sasion raison avait été voté
au sénat en première lecture enlevé par
l'assemblée nationale cette semaine vous
allez le réintroduire dans le texte mais
sur comprenons les choses il ya un grand
combat contre l'islamisme c'est le
combat de notre génération c'est un
totalitarisme or on sait grâce à des
universitaires je pense à bernard ogiez
les territoires conquis voilà la
république eh bien je pense que
l'entrisme désormais ce sont les stades
ce sont les terrains de sport c'est un
fait établi par des universitaires or le
sport doit être ce rêve d'universel doit
être ce rêve d'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes et je crois que aucun
signe religieux ostentatoire n'a sa
place dans les stades essayons préserver
la charte olympique l'esprit du sport
qui est une grammaire universel voilà
qui est un langage n'ya pas d'espéranto
le sol espéranto qu'il y ait surtout les
cinq continents voilà sont les règles
d'un match de foot d'un match de basket
c'est et ils ne pourront pas avec des
signes religieux ou même politique
d'ailleurs ce moment qu est un moment
humain important justement est ce que le
sport n'est pas un moyen d'émancipation
et pourrait intégrer ces femmes voilées
les sortir des quartiers moi c'est
extraordinaire vous me sortez
la rhétorique des frères musulmans ou
des salafistes en dix ans mais elles ont
bien le droit de porter le hidjab le
voile aller dans les pays allait dans
les pays qui sont dirigés par des frères
musulmans il faut faire et ce qu'il en
est de la liberté non ils sont
intelligents c'est à dire que il
retourne les idéaux de la démocratie
contre la démocratie mais une fois de
plus il ne s'agit pas de guerre
religieuse il s'agit simplement d'un
combat politique le voile le voile est
le signe d'un apartheid sexuel le signe
de la soumission de la sape la femme et
c'est le signe d'un séparatisme qui
signifie on n'est pas comme vous on
constitue dans la communauté nationale
un corps étranger ça n'est pas ça la
république la république sait quelle que
soit sa religion quelle que soit sa
condition sociale quelle que soit la
couleur de sa peau participez au même
espace civique mettre à l'écart des
particularités le communautarisme
l'islamisme c'est au contraire exalté ce
qui vous sépare du reste de la
population eh bien on doit mener ce
combat ce combat il est pas seulement
policier judiciaire il est culturel
c'est ce qu'ils veulent macron
d'ailleurs n'a pas compris il faut être
ferme c'est un combat qui concerne
désormais les esprits c'est ce que nous
apprend d'ailleurs le meurtre
l'assassinât du père hamel on sent
d'ailleurs qu'à les divisions sur ce
sujet du voile dans le sport au sein
même du gouvernement avec une isabelle
moreno qui est pour le port du voile
dans le sport est en faveur de ces
hidjab jean michel blanquer un match à
part qui ne l'est pas dénoncent la
religion dans ces compétitions mais
c'est lui en même temps quoi que jean
michel blanquer je me souviens toujours
refusé lorsqu'on a voté par exemple
l'interdiction des signes ostentatoires
religieux pour les sorties scolaires il
a toujours refusé donc vous savez tout
ça est une apparence et mal macro on en
revient au fameux discours à quoi ça
sert des dix quartz quoi ça sert une
preuve une présidence verbe une
présidence bavarde si c'est pour que les
mots tombent par terre et ne
correspondent pas aux actes je pense que
les français veulent autre chose c'est
peut-être que very pécresse pourrait
leur offrir on va évoquer une autre
actualité bruno retailleau celle du
convoi de la liberté qui a été mobilisé
en france ce week-end notamment à paris
beaucoup de tension sur les
champs-elysées avec une centaine de
personnes interpellées la cette semaine
le combat de la liberté se dirige à
bruxelles pour se réunir avec d'autres
convois européen est ce qu'on est en
train de vivre peut-être le début d'une
nouvelle crise du gilet jaune
écoutez on a un pays qui est très
éruptif et et moi en réalité ma crainte
elle est la suivante j'ai vécu vous
disiez tout à l'heure la campagne il ya
cinq ans il ya eu la jana judiciaire qui
a percuté l'agenda démocratique et on
n'a pas eu un vrai débat
là mails macron et candidats bien sûr
mais il veut pas faire campagne il se
met sur l'olympe jupiter en contrechamp
de tous les autres candidats pour en
réalité échapper à son bilan mais si on
a pas de campagne
cinq ans après qu'on ait pas eu de
campagne alors ce sont des graines de
colère je pense que le débat
démocratique en sortir a amputé et
lorsque le débat démocratique est
inexistant à ce moment là les gens ne
parlent pas travers des urnes mais c'est
souvent la violence de la rue qui prend
le relais pour vous la question des
gilet jaune n'a pas été réglé non entre
les mesures annoncées n'a pas été réglé
parce que moi j'aurais voulu que parmi
ses grandes promesses le président de
république souhaiter réconcilier les
français au point qu'il souhaitait
effacer le clivage traditionnel entre la
droite et la gauche je suis désolé on a
une france qui est plus divisé que
jamais comment un président de la
république
a pu dire que il voulait emmerder les
non vaccinés est pire que c'est non
vaccinés n'avaient pas le statut de
concitoyens aucun président de la
république sous la vème république n'a
proféré ce genre de choses c'est
extrêmement grave il n'a pas su
malheureusement être l'homme de la
nation c'est lui qui a appuyé sur le
bouton c'est en mode écoute a levé gilet
jaune c est mal macro ont d'ailleurs
riant de l'avion dénoncé au sénat vous
savez que dans le plf nous sommes au
moins de décembre je crois 2017 quand on
vote le projet de loi de finances et on
se rend compte que il ya des dizaines de
milliards d'euros dans une trajectoire
de fiscalité sur le diesel etc et on
avait dit à l'époque méfiez vous vous
pourriez avoir les bérets rouges on
s'est trompé de couleur on s'est trompé
de feu de vêtements rue moneo jamais les
bonnets rouges pardon on avait très
clairement dit que attention il y avait
une limite à ne pas franchir et on avait
mis en garde au gouvernement c'était le
gouvernement d'ailleurs d'edouard
philippe bond notable justement sur
cette opposition au pass vaccinale on a
une vingtaine de sénateurs les
républicains qui signe une tribune dans
le journal le figaro pour demander
immédiatement la levée du pass vaccinale
est pas à début avril comme c'est
annoncé par le gouvernement vous n'avez
pas signé cette tribune j'ai bien
cherché à la signature vous êtes en
désaccord avec cette tribune non mais on
a des sénateurs qui ne vais pas voter le
passage du ter et qui n'avait pas voté
le pass vaccinale vingtaine sur 150
croyez moi sur ce genre de l'histoire
c'est normal chacun peut exprimer ses
souhaits et ses choix moi je pense que
le moment viendra bientôt qu'on puisse
lever les contraintes ça comment je
rappelle que dans quelques jours vous
pourrez élections tous à aller en boîte
de nuit si vous êtes vacciné il ya un
allègement du protocole pour pour
l'école moi je pense que le kazakh sinal
n'a pas vocation à durer je ne veux pas
qu'on installe les français dans la
société du contrôle permanent c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons confié à
la commission des affaires sociales
présidée par catherine de roche des
pouvoirs de commission d' enquête pour
voir si le pass vaccinale est toujours
adaptée à la situation épidémique et je
vois qu'il ya plus de 50 millions de
français qui sont vaccinées quinzaine de
millions voire plus désormais qui ont
été infectés dans je pense que d'ici
quelques semaines il faudra
vraisemblablement dire voilà il faut
passer à autre chose en tout cas on ne
peut pas vivre en permanence avec le
pass vaccinale j'observe d'ailleurs
qu'il ya un gros ralentissement des
vaccinations et qu'on va atteindre
bientôt le noyau dur pour les ceux qui
les ont dit vax notamment qui ne sont
pas vaccinés et on finit par une
question internationale sur l'ukraine
avec une menace imminente d'invasion du
territoire du territoire ukrainien par
la russie emmanuel macron s'est de
nouveau entretenu avec le président
russe vladimir poutine et il a dit au
président russe sa détermination à agir
si jamais il y avait une invasion russe
est ce que vous croyez à ce dialogue
mené par emmanuel macron avec magnan
poutine et est ce qu'on peut est ce que
vous faites confiance avec à vladimir
poutine
en matière de géopolitique
ont fait pas confiance on fait le
dialogue le dialogue pour la paix
vous avez employé le mot imminent c'est
ce que la diplomatie américaine utilise
comme qualificative depuis des semaines
moi je n'ai pas du tout d'information je
pense que c'est un être rationnel alors
d'un côté cet être rationnel peut
considérer que lui il veut neutraliser
il ne veut pas que l'ukraine rentrer
dans le temps il a ses raisons que je
pense et je crois que le temps a eu tort
dans les années 90 de ne pas respecter
la parole qu'ils avaient été données par
james baker l'américain est
monsieur kohl au moment de la
réunification il avait dit notamment à
monsieur gorbatchev qui leur avait
demandé de ne pas se rapprocher avec le
temps des frontières de la russie dont
vous inquiétez pas donc monsieur poutine
à cette volonté la donne côté il y a il
est rationnel et je pense que s'il subit
des pressions économiques ça peut coûter
très cher le problème est que lui à
cette volonté de reconstituer un empire
la russie n'a jamais été un état nation
la russie a toujours été un empire le
propre d'un empire c'est de ne pas avoir
des frontières où les frontières assez
floue d'en vouloir toujours plus donc il
faut se méfier ils verront reconstituer
un socle en plus ethnique les grands
russe la russie les petits russes les
ukrainiens et puis les russes blancs
nabil russie voilà donc il faut se
méfier il faut entrez les muscles tout
en dialoguant mais pour l'instant il n'y
a pas eu d' invasion y at il une
invasion imminente je ne sais pas en
tout cas j'observe que d'un côté
monsieur poutine veut obtenir un
résultat c'est à dire faire en sorte que
l'ukraine soit fan en dise est
neutralisée et de l'autre côté les
américains finalement on réinstalle et
l'otan au coeur du système de sécurité
européen pendant que c'est une sorte de
jeu de dupes aussi et il faut essayer de
prendre un peu de hauteur bruno
retailleau avant de clore cet entretien
je vous fait réagir sur une information
de dernière minute un homme a menacé
deux policiers avec un couteau ça se
passe et gare du nord à paris et elle et
deux policiers ont riposté en tirant il
a été tué est ce que pour vous c'est une
réponse qui vous semblent proportionnée
à première vue écoutez bien sûr moi je
fais confiance aux policiers il était en
état de légitime défense et ça permet de
faire usage des armes mais vous voyez
cette information elle se relit elle se
reconnecte à tout ce que nous avons dit
pendant cette émission nous sommes en
guerre en guerre contre l'islamisme et
quand je vois cette naïveté de la macro
ni du président de la république à ne
pas mener une guerre dans toutes ses
dimensions y compris culturel je pense
que de ce point de vue là nous sommes
dans un état de faiblesse et les
islamistes le sens très très bien alors
on précise pour l'instant au vu de cette
information rien ne précise que l'homme
était islamisme et je voulais vous faire
réagir rapidement sur ce fait ce fait
divers merci beaucoup pour nous c'est
d'avoir à notre invité politique
aujourd'hui
[Musique]